in the
the universe will tell us
thank you good afternoon it's a pleasure
to be here I was last here at Carnegie
Mellon about ten years ago and just Fred
pointed out my life happened to turn a
corner then I learned enough about
viruses to decide that it was time i
chime the first experiment in my
professional life and that I think
seriously about biology for the first
time I I I as a student was enamored of
not my father my twin brother we're
mathematicians is a beautiful world I
learned about growing up and I wanted to
do something different so I became a
theoretical physical scientist but
indeed I was enamored of equations and
in beautiful theories I still AM
but I didn't realize what I was missing
I was convinced that a physical theorist
couldn't contribute anything significant
to biology because biological systems
were just too complicated there were no
general laws in biology I'm quoting my
ignorant former self
so I managed in high school not to take
the obligatory course in biology same
thing in college so people think I'm
being modest when I say that when I
started 10 years ago working on viruses
I knew no biology I mean I knew no
biology possibly less because of the
great effort I've made not to learn
anything but when I learned what a virus
was and how simple it is as a physical
object my professional life change in
that I realized I was determined to do
anything I had to do including start a
lab in order to understand viruses real
viruses
models of viruses so of course as a
theorist I continue to make models of
viruses
it's how I understand anything I'm
thinking about in science but the models
the theories are explicitly intended to
be tested by an experiment that we're
designing at the same time so in our
research group now we have six eight PhD
and postdoctoral students and generally
no more than one of them is working on a
theoretical problem the others are in
the lab working on a different virus why
on earth would we work on several
viruses when we start out knowing no
biology and biology we wanted to bring
to virology a different point of view as
a physical theorist
again it was natural to look for general
behavior so I wanted to know I still
wanted to know every year along the way
and today what do all viruses have in
common what is virus what qualifies
something to be called a virus so I'm
gonna go through a lot of history I
think half of my talk is the history of
virology but I hope you'll agree that
after we go through that history you
will have learned some things about
viruses it happens my wife is a
historian of science and early on I I
learned that studying history of science
tells you a lot about scientific ideas
and it's all the more true in the case
of virology because you have to ask
right away
why are viruses only something we know
about in the last century the concept of
virus was not clarified before 100 years
ago
so I want to talk about that phenomenon
and how much you learn about viruses by
going through the early history the
prehistory of viruses viruses from
scratch yes one of our big efforts is to
make viruses from purified components
and
science to make them from scratch but I
also intended it with a another meaning
I'm starting from scratch
telling you about viruses assuming you
know nothing about them assuming you
knew you know as little as I knew when I
started will be asking lots of questions
I warned you will be asking what are
viruses what's a virus what isn't a
virus and in particular what about them
accounts for why they will only
discovered 100 years ago a question that
often comes up is our virus is alive we
can talk about that after the lecture
you can ask questions about it it's an
interesting question but one can also
argue it's not important instead talk
about what they do
I argue it's useful not to think of them
as being alive and that helps you
understand why they can be such simple
evolving organisms if you like they
evolved no differently in fact much
better than truly living things faster
and better but they can have as few as
one or two genes the business of life is
much more complicated than what can be
coded for in one or two genes you know
that there are many proteins that come
from the same gene so there's a huge
number of proteins that function in
different ways to keep us alive keep us
healthy compared to the number of genes
that are identified in a genome a virus
can have one or two genes so you have to
ask what are they for to to allow the
thing to act as a virus and that gets us
into the question of what are the
generic life cycles I'm going to show
you three life cycles there's a life
cycle for every virus and there's a
essentially infinite number of viruses
we're talking earlier today about how
easy it is to discover and
virus dig up some dirt look under the
microscope and you'll see some new
viruses but why will I show you only
three life cycles because maybe that's
already too many you see that they all
have something in common
so we'll get to the heart of what a
virus is by looking at life cycles
associated with viruses that infect
bacteria or plants or animals
that's as different as their hosts can
be so you'd expect the biggest
differences in those viruses and yet
there are dramatic similarities profound
ones between viruses that infect totally
different kinds of hosts this is one of
the questions that drew me into viruses
as a theorist and it accounts for why
viruses as physical objects are as
beautiful as they are
I want to insist I apologize beforehand
for talking about many times throughout
the lecture how beautiful virus is our
and so we know that they're ugly
insidious deadly painful horrible
disease agents so when I talk about
viruses being beautiful I'm talking
about the virus particle and related to
these other questions why how can we
make viruses from purified components in
a test-tube you can't make a bacterium
or any other one celled or more
complicated living organism from scratch
you don't know what the parts list is
you don't know what to begin with and
there's no way you could control all the
conditions necessary for the
evolutionary of that living thing
simplest viruses are just protected
genetic information so the simplest
virus at the very least has to have a
genome that codes for at least one
protein unlike all other evolving
organisms and certainly all living
things the genome needn't be DNA we talk
about DNA is the genetic material most
viruses have as their genetic material
are in a single-stranded RNA they need
to be protected and they're protected by
a one protein thick shell which in most
cases is spherical in most of the cases
when the shell is empirical it's
cylindrical or out like sometimes you
have a combination of the two like in
bacterial viruses as I'll show you we
speak about a head and a tail it's
really a spherical head that protects
the genetic material in a tail for
delivering the material and in the case
of many mammalian viruses certainly
human viruses there's an extra layer of
protection
it's a lipid bilayer envelope that
surrounds the protein shell and that's
important for the virus to get into and
out of cells everybody knows what
double-stranded DNA looks like I was
walking through the campus holding one
of my favorite DNA duplex models to
bring to a friend and there was some
five year old kids playing and and one
of them called out to their father look
dad that guy has a DNA so this is an
icon really of of biology the double
helix what people are less familiar with
is single-stranded DNA or
single-stranded RNA it's essentially the
same polymer but with some crucial diff
ribonucleic acid meaning a ribose sugar
rather than the deoxy sugar but that's
the difference between a H and a OS
group and then one of the nucleotides
one of the bases is different the T of
DNA of the four-letter alphabet is
slightly different that small difference
makes a difference but the important
point I want to emphasize from the
outset is that the genomes of most
viruses are single stranded RNA so it's
a theme of our research to know the
physical properties of each of the
genomes a lot is known about
double-stranded DNA as a poly
electrolyte as a physical object it's a
stiff polymer it's been studied from
every point of view but single-stranded
RNA is much less well understood and
much more complicated let's start asking
some physical questions
how big is a virus when I teach I like
to insist that you can make an order of
magnitude estimate of anything if you
understand just a little bit about it
how do you figure out how big a virus
particle is whether it's a micron or an
angstrom well it clearly has to be small
compared to its host cell in a host cell
is that these microns in dimension so a
virus has to be very small compared to
that notice already we need to know
something about biology we need to know
the size of cells and we also need to
know that when a virus goes through a
life cycle and is replicated you go from
one virus to thousands or tens of
thousands of virus particles the size of
a viral litter is on the order of a
thousand the just station period is
hours that's why they that's one of the
reasons they have all so fast and out
evolve their hosts or the immune system
or prescribed antiviral treatments
so on so it's got to be small compared
to this and yet it's got to be big
enough to enclose a few genes so let's
ask how big a gene is you saw the
familiar double stranded helix the
helical repeat 10 base pairs is 3 and
1/2 nanometers the width of the four
diameters couple nanometers so you can
ask if you need say a thousand base
pairs and that's roughly what you need
to code for a small protein how much
volume do you need to accommodate that
amount of genetic information and then
ask well what about 10 genes because 10
genes is the typical genetic content of
a virus and it turns out you need the
volume of tens of thousands of cubic
nanometers and you ask how big a sphere
would you need for that a sphere with a
diameter of tens and animators so it
tells you a virus should be tens and
nano meters in size and the remarkable
fact is that all viruses are this size
although they're big ones and small ones
and are always exceptions there's some
few outliers but to within a factor of
two the overwhelming majority of viruses
are 50 nanometers in size that's why
nobody ever saw them under an optical
microscope the way you see a bacterium
it's also why they couldn't be filtered
out of a body fluid when the microbe
hunters in the last century were looking
for microbes disease agents they took
blood lymph feces and ran it through a
filter and the bacteria got caught in
the filter and they discovered lots of
disease agents that way they didn't
discover viruses that way because even
the finest filter wasn't fine enough to
catch a virus so I mentioned that virus
is only discovered 100 years ago the
first one tobacco mosaic virus was
discovered in the late
1890s that particular virus plays a very
important role in the history of
virology it was the first to be
crystallized that was in the 30s and
remember people didn't know much about
what a virus was then in terms of
protein nucleic acid content how it
worked but they did think of it as alive
and no living thing had ever been
crystallized it's hard enough
crystallizing proteins those of you who
do protein crystallography try
crystallizing a bacterium or a micro
forget it we need a highly monodisperse
same size same shape regular thing to
crystallize it living things are not
highly monodisperse
that we have no symmetry you know we
talk about people having right left
symmetry we do approximately but we have
no symmetry in a strict sense a protein
molecule has no symmetry but it turns
out that a virus particle does and it
has the highest possible symmetry it's
an aggregate of proteins it's the first
to be crystallized it was the first to
be reconstituted from purified
components I was in the mid 50s I'll
talk about that shortly and again nobody
had ever heard about reconstituting a
living organism and I was suggesting we
never will first animal virus was
discovered about the same time
foot-in-mouth disease virus the first
cell cultures were developed for animal
virus plaque assays in the early 50s and
that revolutionized virology and in
medicine first vaccines in the mid 50's
first serious discussion of using
viruses as vectors for delivering genes
that were missing were effective in in
cells started in the 70s first virus
that infected bacteria was discovered in
the course of World War one
I want to tell you that story in a
moment viruses and in particular
bacterial viruses called for short
bacteriophage or phage played a vital
role in the origin of the field of
molecular biology max Bell Burke and few
others in the 30s and 40s realized that
the virus was a simple enough system for
unraveling on a molecular level the way
in which genetic information is
replicated and expressed the way in
which genes are expressed that was done
the model system so to speak was a
bacterial virus and that was the
beginning of molecular biology the first
e/m pictures of viruses were in the very
early 40s want to say few more words
about history maybe you're familiar with
Koch's postulates German biologist
medical scientist who again certainly
revolutionize bacteriology and medicine
discovering the disease agents for
tuberculosis many other diseases and he
got serious about how you hunt a microbe
and establish that it's the causative
agent for disease you have to be able to
find it in diseased tissue in every
instance of the disease you have to be
able to isolate it purify it and grow it
insult culture or rather in sorry I'm
thinking about viruses jumping ahead you
have to grow it in in nutrient broth
just give it some food middle girl it's
alive grow it and then in fact healthy
tissue with it and find the same disease
and recover the same disease agent so
this made the 19th century especially in
Europe the century of microbe hunting it
was a very exciting time Pasteur got
involved
but the reason viruses weren't
discovered is for the reasons I already
have hinted at they were too small to
see in a microscope once you isolate
them they're too small to be caught in a
filter and when you try to satisfy
another one of Koch's postulates grow it
up in nutrient broth it doesn't grow
that's because it needs to be in its
host
it's an obligate parasite it's not an
independent organism it's a picture of
the kind of porcelain filter that was
used you're forced with a hand pump of
body fluid or ground-up leaves if you
were looking for the causative agent of
tobacco mosaic disease Chamberlain was
an assistant of Pasteur who developed
this viruses were discovered only when
people started looking in the filtrate
what got through the filter it's
interesting that that cholera was
discovered in the COFF sense and
inoculation was developed against it by
doing just this an interesting story it
was discovered by accident glad to talk
to you about it later what I want to
stress now is that Pasteur was famous
for many things inoculating against
cholera inoculating color is the
bacterial disease he's famous for
inoculating against rabies
now rabies is a viral disease but he
didn't know it and earlier
Jenner in the late 18th century had
inoculated against smallpox he didn't
know that it was a virus he didn't
always different from a bacterium this
was long before cough
this guy who's not as famous as pastor I
think should be given credit for
discovering the difference between a
virus and a bacterium he was a
bacteriologist so he tried to he
isolated the he collected the filtrate
from ground-up leaves from plants
infected with tobacco mosaic disease and
I he couldn't grow it in nutrient broth
he found he could only grow it if he
reinfected plants with it and so he made
that distinction the word virus had been
used by Pasteur and others it's from the
Latin poison so it was a generic term at
the same time he's German medical
scientists discovered open mouth virus
by looking at the bacterial free
filtrates of infectious material from
sick cattle and they point out that the
causal agents of a large number of other
infectious diseases such as smallpox cow
pox it's called a fever measles typhus
cattle plague cetera might turn out to
be similar organisms
Derrell and thwart in England discovered
bacterial viruses and I like this
account by Darrell of his discovery he
was a medical doctor treating an
outbreak of dysentery
that's a bacterial infection and
unpleasant intestinal infection and he
says I made an emulsion of some of the
still bloody stool and filtered it
through one of these porcelain candles
and to a broth culture of dysentery
bacillus meaning the bacteria causing
the dysentery that he had isolated a few
days earlier I added a job of the
filtrate and spread a job of this agar
the next morning on opening the
incubator I
experienced one of those rare moments of
intense emotion this guy was serious as
we all are I mean which reward the
research worker for his veins at the
first glance I saw that the broth
culture which the night before had been
very turbid was perfectly clear all the
bacteria had vanished
of course they hadn't vanished they had
been infected by the virus and I'll show
you a picture of what a bacterial cell
looks like infected by virus virus it's
filled with thousands of virus particles
and the only way they get out is by
lysis or breaking of the cell membrane
induced by one of the viral gene
products okay so it's a part of the life
cycle to destroy the cell membrane of
the host so that all the new copies of
the virus can get out so when you slice
the cell you can no longer see it under
an optical microscope this is the first
eeehm picture it's not very impressive
there it is that's the bacterial virus
that's the bacterium here's a scale bar
he's happened to be pictures that
alexeyevitch took 65 years later you can
see a lot more of what's going on
apparently in the late 40s Roger correct
me if I'm wrong I think that's when Dell
Brooke first saw an e/m of a phage and
exclaimed in German my god they have
tails that certainly wasn't apparent
here but it is in a better quality
picture I put a scale bar in here but I
like to be mischievous perverse I show
electron micrographs without putting in
a scale bar if it's a virus you don't
need a scale bar they're all 15
nanometers okay modulo a factor of 2 but
understand what's going on that's good
enough here's my favorite picture
happens to be free-tailed bacterial
viruses tricked into thinking that this
closed lipid bilayer
that's been reconstituted with a few
molecules of the receptor for this virus
it thinks but it's not thinking it's not
alive it's diffusing around like a
Brownian particle its tail hits that
receptor protein and that triggers the
release of the genome into the aqueous
buffer solution inside this vesicle we
happen to put some polyvalent cations
there to condense the DNA and indeed
this is the kind of DNA structure that I
was working on in the late 1990s before
I knew what a virus was I didn't even
know what the person in the street knows
about viruses another one of my
idiosyncrasies is that I don't read the
newspaper much or much television at all
and so I miss a lot of good things like
the health section that tells you a
little about viruses and has pictures
but I was this is three molecules of
double-stranded DNA three genomes from
these viruses that have been condensed
exactly close packed by polyvalent
cations I'm exaggerating here it might
only be 15 orders of magnitude simpler
than any living object and it's because
I would argue they're not alive they
have no metabolism they don't grow you
speak about maturation of virus
particles but effectively all that
happens in a viral life cycle is nothing
at all until they're replicated and you
go from one to thousands of copies you
know proper host cell nevertheless I've
already emphasized that viruses have
evolved to do precisely this in a
alarmingly effective way they get their
genetic information into a hotel they
pirate the biochemical machinery of the
host cell it's the ultimate challenge
for them and for us as scientists to
understand regulation of gene expression
the viruses are all about regulating or
miss regulating gene expression in an
infected cell
essentially all the genes being
expressed and therefore all the proteins
being synthesized are those of the virus
not the whole cell that's why your host
cells are sick and why you can die very
quickly because within hours you go from
one virus in a Cell to thousands of
particles being made each of which
infects another cell within hours I
emphasize again let's go through the
textbook pictures of viral life cycles
I'm sure everybody's seen pictures like
this including in the health section of
the newspapers here you have this is a
schematic of the viral shell with the
genome inside the lipid bilayer envelope
around it and then transmembrane
proteins that are important for getting
the virus in and out of cells comes in
through a process called endocytosis
where picks up another layer of envelope
I'd also come in by the two envelopes
fusing but the important point is that
the naked capsid is delivered to the
cytoplasm the genome is released a large
number of copies of the genome are made
maybe millions you then express the
genes of that genome and you make still
more copies of structural proteins like
the proteins that make up the capsid and
then you make thousands of copies of the
virus and they get out in this case by
exocytosis by picking up their membrane
by stealing a piece of membrane from the
host cell in the case of a plant cell
essentially the same thing happens all
viral life cycles are the same in that
they deliver the genome large number of
copies of the genome are made and then
you make still larger numbers of the
structural proteins of the virus the
fundamental difference in a plant cell
is that there's a rigid cell wall so you
don't have a delicate membrane protein
receptor mediated entry process the
infection of the cell depends on slight
injury to the cell wall
a leaf might blow against the trunk of
the tree
an insect might be nibbling on one end
of the leaf and do some damage to the
cell walls not enough to hurt the cell
much but enough for a large number of
virus particles to come in and start an
infection in the case of bacterial
viruses again it's the same fundamental
cycle genome comes in many copies made
genes express many structural proteins
made many copies of the virus go on to
infect other cells but this is the first
life cycle we looked at and as I was
reading undergraduate textbooks trying
to learn about biology and about viruses
I saw this cartoon and I asked the
simple question what drives this
ejection or injection of the genome the
cartoon showed the virus particles
staying outside the cell in the case of
the plant and animal viral life cycles
the whole viral particle comes in and
that means you have to find a way to
understand what drives the delivery
process this is a famous experiment that
was done in 1952 it's cited most often
as providing confirmation that DNA is
the transforming material the genetic
material but in fact for our purposes
what's important about it is that it
proved that the virus particle the
capsid stays outside the protective
shell stays outside you radio label the
protein your radio label the DNA and
midway through the infection process you
put your sample in a kitchen blender and
knock off the capsid and palate the
cells collect all the cell's in a
centrifuge and what you find you
that the only radioactively-labeled
material is DNA only the DNA has come in
no protein so again it points up the
fact that something drives the DNA in
and to show that same picture here and
the question we ask here is electron
micrograph of a fairly infected cell
there are barely even a hundred
particles here there's room and you're
just seeing in the plane of focus before
this cell has its outer membrane broken
lies there will be thousands of
particles made each one going on to
infect another single cell in this case
it appears there were two viruses that
injected their DNA to start the
infection it's been recognized by
several people this is cartoon we are
drawn for a commentary last year making
an analogy between how a bacterial virus
delivers its genome in how a mammalian
or human virus delivers its genome I had
said before that emphasize just now that
it's with a few exceptions only the
bacterial virus that stays outside the
cell in the case of plant and animal
viral infections the whole virus
particle comes inside so you don't have
the problem of explaining how the genome
gets inside in the case of herpes which
you know all too well is a very
successful predator of humans
it's an enveloped virus which means you
have the genome you have the protein
shell protecting it and then you have
the lipid bilayer the piece of membrane
a fluid membrane protecting it you have
fusion of this membrane with the cell
membrane you have a naked capsid that is
trafficked through the cytoplasm to the
nucleus
the genome is DNA a DNA virus has to get
its DNA into the nucleus that's where
DNA is replicated and that's where genes
are expressed and yet the analogy
between the two is that the capsid
doesn't enter the nucleus it there's a
membrane around the nucleus there's a
pore complex and binding to the pore
complex triggers the injection of the
DNA so there's reason to believe that
it's the same physical mechanism that
drives these genome deliveries and that
mechanism is pressure this is a famous
photograph from many decades ago it's an
electron micrograph of a bacterial virus
that's been broken in this case by
osmotic shock what you see here is the
genome that had been protected inside
the head notice I have no scale bar the
head is 50 nanometers in diameter this
DNA is tens of microns long so it's many
hundreds of times longer this dimension
is a micron so it's tens of times bigger
than the the head and this is a single
molecule of DNA you're used to looking
at DNA as a double helix on an atomistic
level but this is the double helix and
it's a pretty stiff molecule because of
the base pairing and stacking and in
fact you know what 50 nanometers looks
like you'll never see DNA spontaneously
bending into a radius of curvature
smaller than 50 nanometers that's the
persistence length that's the one the
elastic modulus of double-stranded DNA
and this is one of the ways to measure
it you just see by definition only
thermal energy is available to bend this
DNA
and that's why it's never bent into two
smaller radius of curvature and yet all
this DNA which has two charges per base
pair two phosphates on the side chains
per base pair so it's got a very high
charge density along its length it's
hard to bend and yet it was confined at
close packing densities inside this
shell so we asked the simple question
how much work do you have to do to take
double-stranded DNA and confine it this
strongly and you can ask how much work
you have to do you can ask what the
stored energy density is that's
effectively the pressure and we found a
surprising result it was 50 atmospheres
and it was hard to believe so we knew it
had to be measured and the first
experiment we did in our lab was done by
alexei ivanovich we didn't have a lab
when he came to his credit he built the
lab and did this experiment and
everything depends on this fact about
the relative size of the viral genome
and the viral capsid now remember that
the capsid I haven't said it yet
is formed by the self-assembly of one of
the gene products of the virus namely
the capsid protein self-assembles to
make an empty shell 50 nanometers in
diameter another punch of viral gene
products make certain that you get
replication of the genome to a high
level some other gene products make
certain including a very strong protein
motor that you can do enough work to
stuff this DNA into the capsid okay so
why would it be that a virus evolved to
depend on so much work being done
building up such a high pressure things
that evolve are things that survive the
only viruses that survive are ones that
are strongly enough pressurized to
deliver their genome to a host cell
this picture so rather this is the
picture I want to do reaction to this is
a picture we took just this year postdoc
in the group at J Gopal this is an
electron micrographic cryo-electron
microscopy is one copy chlorotic model
virus and this is the analog of the
picture you see here we are showing
juxtaposed next to each other the viral
genome and the capsid inside which the
genome is confined you notice that this
RNA molecule has the same dimensions as
the volume in which it's confined
consistent with the fact that this is
just a solution of purified RNA we threw
in some virus but what we normally do is
to have purified solution of RNA no
virus around and we throw in some
purified capsid protein the capsid
protein that is one of the four gene
products of this simple virus you mix
those two purified components in pH 7
buffer and they spontaneously organize
themselves into infectious virus
particles not just fear achill but
icosahedron asymmetric shells one
protein thick 180 copies of the protein
repeated to make the shell and one and
only one molecule of the RNA inside so
this genome gets packaged protected by a
spontaneous self-assembly process
whereas the double-stranded DNA virus
has its genome packaged and protected by
a lot of work being done by a arguably
the strongest motor protein known the
gene product of that particular virus
the bacteriophage are herpes whatever so
that's a fundamental physical difference
when the genomes of double-stranded DNA
viruses and single-stranded RNA viruses
and that's how we try to understand how
viruses work and why we we recall what
we're doing physical virology because
instead of asking genetic or biochemical
questions about the virus whereas some
physical questions in order to
understand how the virus works what
makes it infective so again it's this
fact which had been suspected but never
demonstrated directly we had done
several years have worked with standard
methods for determining the sizes and
shapes of large polymers biomolecules
like viral genomes small angle x-ray
scattering diffusion coefficient
measurements but it didn't give us
direct information about size and shape
that we get in this electron microscopy
so I've just summed up what I've told
you so far how we think about the
physical difference between DNA and RNA
viruses basically we say it's no
surprise that viruses that don't enter
the host cell but rather deliver the
genome need to be pressurized therefore
they need a double-stranded DNA genome
double-stranded RNA would work too but
the large majority of viruses bacteria
phages that depend on pressure have
double stranded DNA viral genomes the
large majority of plant and animal
viruses have single-stranded RNA genomes
because they don't depend on the genome
being stiff big and hard to confine
without a lot of work being done in fact
they depend on the genome being
spontaneously packaged through self
assembly with the capsid protein we've
been working the last few years on
enveloped viruses and in particular
trying to make one from scratch it's
something I'm glad to talk about
afterwards
we have some results after five years
but we haven't yet succeeded in making
from purified component
let's see it's one two three four five
components RNA genome capsid protein 2
membrane proteins and lipid we haven't
succeeded in making the full infectious
virus yet only halves of it we can't
quite put them together and get the
infectious virus
I mentioned tobacco mosaic virus before
it's the first one discovered the first
one crystallized this is what it looks
like it's a remarkably same size same
shape virus happens to be rigid
cylindrical rods hollow one protein
thick shells with one molecule of RNA
inside and this was reconstituted in
infectious form from purified capsid
protein in RNA
I was done in 55 a decade later a
similar experiment was done with
purified capsid protein and RNA genome
from a spherical virus is simple plant
virus in fact the one that we do most of
our work on establishing that this is a
spontaneous self-assembly process and
that yes you depend on evolution to give
you a protein that will spontaneously
self-assemble with its genome but it
didn't take place in the hotel you don't
need host cell cofactors I want to come
back to the kind of physical questions
we asked about viruses to understand
them once we know how big a virus is we
settle that question earlier by doing a
simple calculation now we want to know
typically how many capsid proteins do
you need to make up the shell and you
know the size of a protein it's a few
nanometers you know a typical radius for
the shell there for you you can find
that there are on the order of hundreds
of proteins you need to make a one
protein
shell that's 50 nanometers in diameter
okay how much RNA can fit inside well
you can figure out the volume inside
suppose you had RNA at maximum density
one gram for cc thousand Dalton's per
cubic nanometer it would tell you how
much RNA you can have inside that
corresponds it turns out to just a few
RNA genes so this is the way we figure
out how many genes a virus has typically
it has on the order of a few big viruses
have hundreds small ones have a few
typically you have tens of genes to do
the job of this generic life cycle I
showed you there's a remarkable paper by
Crick and Watson a three-page paper in
Nature 1956
nowhere near as famous as the 1953 paper
Watson and Crick on the structure of the
double helix but I think it's a more
impressive paper period I tell my theory
students it's one of the more impressive
pieces of theory done in science period
because without any equations without
any computations with some deep thinking
about biology and this was before the
genetic code was deciphered before
people knew about messenger RNA the
central dogma how you go from DNA genes
to protein products and so on they
realized that there's only room for a
few genes there had an idea of how big a
gene had to be and they realized
immediately the capsid must be made up
of many copies of a single gene product
instead of having many genes coding for
many proteins of different times that
would make up the shell there isn't room
to code that much information so waste
only one gene and the capsid protein and
try to understand how a symmetric shell
can be formed from
a single molecule and then they did some
basic group theory without calling it
such and they figured out that the
symmetry of viruses should correspond to
cubic point groups basically their idea
was that if a single kind of molecule
makes up the shell then for the shell to
be stable there should be some optimum
way for that molecule to be surrounded
by neighbors all the molecules should be
similarly surrounded by neighbors to
have a similarly low energy they didn't
even talk about low energy I'm putting a
lot into their argument that's the
genius of of their paper so you need all
the proteins to be in equivalent
positions so they see the same neighbors
nearest neighbors next nearest neighbors
and so on and if you ask yourself how
many points can you put on the surface
of a sphere so that the positions are
equivalent not sort of the same like the
dimples on a golf ball
take a look they're not equivalent you
can't put that many points on the
surface of a sphere and have them
strictly equivalent in the mathematician
sense so this begins to sound like a
geometry problem and it is the answer to
the question is that the maximum number
is 60 Suns counterintuitive you think if
you just spread them out uniformly and
carefully you could go on forever but
it's also come to intuitive that there's
a limit to the number of perfect
polyhedra there are only five in the
icosahedron is the biggest one those are
the Platonic solids you would think if
you take regular polygons and you're
careful you can make an arbitrarily
large polyhedron where all the faces are
the same and each is a regular polygon
but you can prove that there only five
and the biggest one is an icosahedron if
you there are 20 equilateral triangle
faces symmetrically put three points on
each face you'll have 60 equivalent
points all the same distance from the
center and all equivalent to each other
that's the prediction that quicken
now Watson made and just reminding you
that that my casa heatran is the highest
point group symmetry have lots of
rotation axes you can't have a center of
inversion you can't have mirror planes
because this is made up of proteins
proteins have no symmetry you have
chiral atoms think about it proteins are
no symmetry but you can have aggregates
of them that have this high symmetry a
dodecahedron 12 pentagonal regular
pentagon faces again it has the same
symmetry as the icosahedron the
mathematician says these are duals of
each other
same symmetry operations and again put
five points on each face symmetrically
and you have 60 equivalent points and
that's what viral capsids look like each
face has proteins you have nothing along
the edges and vertices the faces are
made up by groupings of identical copies
of a single gene product what
Kaspar include did again - great
structural biologists in a single paper
they didn't write a series of papers
there was a single paper in which they
solved the rest of the the problem okay
if you can have 60 proteins that are
equivalent you'd say okay protein shells
to be most stable will have 1660
proteins but that just gives you a cap
sort of a certain size remember all
proteins are a few nanometers in size
you want to make something that has
twice the diameter you need a lot more
proteins okay they won't be equivalent
any longer so these guys asked another
geometry question the shell is
essentially a 2d crystal proteins have
aggregated in 2d but it curves on itself
it's a hexagonal crystal it has that
symmetry and so it's a geometrical
problem a cart and Euler solved that
centuries ago how do you take a
hexagonal crystal and close it on itself
you need to introduce twelve fivefold
defects or diss clinicians or if you
like you need to take hexagons let's see
I made this picture up before I left
home the other night this is my newest
favorite toy for model building polygons
you try to tile the floor with hexagons
no problem you try to do it with
Pentagon's you can't okay
there's an angle deficit there and it
can only be relieved if you want to a
closed shell by coming out of the plane
and so all the curvature comes from
pentameric groupings of proteins and in
this way Casper include figured out what
the sizes of the bigger viruses would be
there would be very discrete sizes
because you either take one step along
this direction and one step along that
other lattice direction and put another
pentameric grouping or you take more
steps along one direction before you do
it
you repeat the process labeled by these
two integers how many steps you take
along each direction twelve times and
you've made a closed shell quickly went
through them now let's go a little more
slowly and I'm almost finished here
indeed the simplest smallest spherical
virus has 60 copies it it is if you like
an icosahedron or equivalently though
diagonal Pentti heejun bigger viruses
like our friend herpes you have to take
four steps along one direction and then
none along the other before you put in a
pentameric grouping remember the
everybody knows what a soccer ball looks
like an old-fashioned soccer ball with
12 black pentagonal faces and 20 more
soccer players aren't aware of this if
you see people playing ball be sure to
stop them and make a nuisance of
yourself 20 white hexagonal faces this
is the next biggest virus particle
that's seen you take one step along one
lattice Direction one step along the
other and you get this structure and
each white hexagon is a hexamer a
grouping of six copies of the capsid
protein each pentagonal face is a
grouping of five copies of the same
protein and when you do the math you see
you have 180 copies of the protein the
next biggest will have 240 copies the
next biggest will have 720 copies and
that corresponds to a discretized set of
diameters in the case of herpes by the
way this T number that's the sum of the
squares and the product of the number of
steps you take along each lattice
direction it's telling you how many
inequivalent positions you have for
these identical proteins so in the case
of the soccer ball when you fill up the
faces with proteins you find that there
are only three in equivalent positions
you want to minimize that number that's
the problem that Kaspar include the
structural biologists solved it's a
geometry problem but no geometry I had
thought about it because he or she
wasn't thinking about viruses in a deep
way my last few slides now maybe you've
seen these pictures quickly I go to some
more here but I'll come back this is
again herpes these are ugly diseases but
this is adenovirus
this is a bacteriophage lambda that we
did our experiments on that played a big
role in the beginning of molecular
biology in the genetic engineering
revolution as a vector for cloning but
you admit every one of these particles
is beautiful they're beautiful because
they have the highest possible symmetry
no living thing has that symmetry okay
this is the plant virus we work on which
has 180 copies of the protein like the
soccer ball structure this is papilloma
here's polyol again ugly diseases
beautiful particles and you remember our
is the diameter or radius the genome
when it's inside is essentially closed
packed and you can easily show that as a
consequence the radius scales with the
cube root of the genome length or the
number of genes the T number the number
of inequivalent positions which is also
telling you how many capsid proteins you
have the number 60 from platonic solids
this is not numerology this is this is I
insist deep science and geometry 60
times the number of in equivalent
positions is the number of copies of the
capsid protein in the size scales as the
square root because the area goes as the
number of proteins so I think it's an
appropriate place to end because it
points up how treating viruses as
physical objects tells you a lot of very
germane and vital things about viral
life cycles and therefore what makes
viruses infectious I've I've collected
some of the conclusions on this slide
I don't care so much about names and
we're talking all day long and many
interesting discussions with the
biological physics group and and and
non-biological physicists but the
importance of doing interdisciplinary
science and that means you shouldn't be
too quick to put labels on what you're
doing don't insists that this work
should interest a particular community
rather insists that you're asking an
important question and you're getting a
good answer to it then you're doing good
science whether it's interesting to
mainstream physicists or chemists or
biologists whatever I think it's pretty
clear that the study of viruses like the
study of material science and so many
other problems in science in the 21st
century has to be approached from a
broad interdisciplinary point of view
I generally count on questions during a
talk I realize it doesn't work in this
kind of venue but I understand you have
questions afterwards and that there's a
reception where we can talk more about
any questions you have thank you very
much
I'm sorry what yes oh sure it doesn't it
doesn't yes
i-i-i think so the question was what's
the connection between I mean most
people throughout the world know this as
a soccer ball all the nerds in the world
know it as a buckyball right this is
carbon 60 buckminsterfullerene and you
can't see but you can imagine the
stitching it's a nice old-fashioned ball
is not a molded plastic one so you have
edges and your vertices do you know how
many vertices there are there's 60
that's why this is a that's why in the
1985 paper announcing the first
fullerene c60 there are three pictures a
high-resolution spectrum the apparatus
molecular beam apparatus and a soccer
ball so even then the carbon atoms are
at the vertices I told you that the
proteins that make up the capsid
protecting the viral genome are not at
the vertices or edges they make up the
faces they make up the planar faces
fives and sixes of them so I think the
chemistry and physics of how the
followings are formed is fundamentally
different from the chemistry and physics
that drives the self-assembly of capsid
proteins to form a structure with the
same symmetry we got this symmetry again
before we started doing experiments were
just asking theory questions we asked
what's special about icosahedral
symmetry we took the idea of Crick and
Watson and Casper include and they were
already figured out the hard thing so we
said let's take their idea literally
let's put points on the surface of a
sphere and have them simply attract each
other isotropically that confined to the
surface of a sphere if they get too
close they repel each other that's the
generic interaction between globular
proteins okay
what's the lowest energy configuration
well keep putting more and more
particles on the surface of the sphere
minimize the energy and ask what's the
energy per particle and you find that it
has an especially low value for certain
multiples of 60 and it corresponds to
icosahedral symmetry that's the physics
behind a capsid looking like a soccer
ball it's electronic structure of carbon
that's behind the geometry of C 60 and
nothing against the followings but
they're ugly compared to viruses C 60 is
exceptional as a highly symmetric
following you have a lot of lower
symmetry followings you you don't have
many lower symmetry virus particles of
course it's biology so you have
exceptions to any rule and there are
some ugly-looking viral particles why
why I remarked that most viral capsids
are spherical and like acetal of the
ones that aren't most are hollow
cylinders so it turns out that those are
the two ways to have many copies of a
protein in a the minimum number of in
equivalent positions in fact in a helix
all of the molecules can be in perfectly
equivalent positions Crick and Watson
pointed that out and that's independent
of how long it is so we could have lived
in a world things could have evolved so
that there were only spherical viruses
but it turns out you can with a single
curvature throughout the full tube no
matter how long it is by the way if you
take the viral genome of tobacco mosaic
virus and you cut it in half as long as
you leave a certain small sequence in
fact and then you add the capsid protein
you will get exactly the same hollow
shells same diameter but half is long so
the RNA is at ten
played for how long the rod is but the
curvature the fact that you form our
hollow rod rather than the sphere has to
do with the subtle aggregation
properties of the protein viral capsid
proteins generically aggregate as a
two-dimensional crystal and the
curvature they prefer enclosing to
protect the genome varies from virus to
virus so the plant virus I showed you
nice spherical capsids with 180 copies
we routinely make it in the lab we can
replace the viral RNA by a bigger RNA
molecule and get a bigger capsid so this
is a capsid protein the the assembly
process isn't as efficient but this
protein prefers a certain curvature and
evolution has made certain that the
viral genome is the right size for the
curvature preferred by the laterally
assembling gene product its capsid
protein but it can also form with less
efficiency a larger capsid or a smaller
one in the case of tobacco mosaic virus
protein you can put in any RNA you like
it'll always form the same two there the
preference for that curvature is
overwhelmingly strong but basically it's
a quirk of evolution that may be
redundant because evolution proceeds
through quirks around the mutations one
of these two geometries works for one
virus and the other works for most
others thank you
it's a good question I'm not sure I know
the answer it's a natural question and
material scientists have asked that
question is there anything special about
again the capsid protein evolved to
prefer a certain curvature you know that
if you had a mutation in the gene for
the capsid protein of one of these
bacterial viruses one of the or herpes
so that it preferred to make a bigger
capsid you'd still have the same genome
line and when the genome was packaged
you wouldn't have a high enough pressure
to deliver the genome you would lose
infective 'ti and that virus wouldn't
survive Alex dies done experiments where
you ask how much pressure do you need in
order for the virus to be infective you
can change the pressure by changing the
length of the genome but keeping all the
genes in fact you can also change the
pressure inside by adding more salt to
the buffer solution and the solution
permeates the capsid and changes the
strength of the repulsions of DNA for
itself so you change the pressure that
way so the pressures probably can be as
high as a hundred atmospheres without
the caps it's breaking however even at
the working pressure of tens of
atmospheres you always have failure
virus caps it's that's why if you store
one of these samples for a few days you
find less infectivity the cap suits are
failing they're pressurized capsules
that are failing just the way high
pressure metal cylinders in your lab
will fail after thousands of years
sometimes sooner than that you have a
shell under stress so it'll fail I don't
know of others single protein thick
structures in biology that have to
withstand pressures this great it's an
interesting question